horas después de que Rusia acusase a
Ucrania de estar detrás de los ataques
con drones contra el crimen Moscú ha
subido la apuesta y ha acusado a Estados
Unidos de ser quien Realmente está
inspirando esta ofensiva con aviones no
tripulados en suelo ruso asegura
Moscú que en realidad es Washington
quien Escoge en muchas ocasiones los
objetivos que han de ser atacados en
suelo Ruso y no kiev recordemos que
estas declaraciones se produce Poco
después de que el secretario de estado
Anthony bliken evitase confirmar si
podía respaldar la idea de que según
Rusia estos ataques han sido obra del
gobierno ucraniano el gobierno de kiev
ha insistido en que ellos no tienen nada
que ver con esta ofensiva con aviones no
tripulados en Moscú y puntualizan que
ellos están luchando pero solo en su
propio territorio es decir en territorio
ucraniano en todo caso Moscú ha
recordado que Se reserva el derecho a la
Facultad a contestar a estos ataques en
el momento y en el lugar que lo
considere oportuno